Now, we didn’t want to start this channel out
with a video about tardigrades.
We wanted to share at least a bit about
some of the other mind blowing organisms of
the microcosmos first.
But we also knew it wasn’t going to be long
before we got to them.
We are, it must be admitted, tardigrade enthusiasts.
And we’ve been excited to watch as a fair
number of people have joined us in that enthusiasm.
However, of course, and we’re not mad about
this, the popular narratives about tardigrades
have, in their enthusiasm, gotten a few things less than correct, and also skipped over some of the most
interesting facets of this celebrity of the
microcosmos.
So...tardigrades.
They’re chubby and they have heads and legs and butts and they look, at first glance, somewhat
familiar.
That’s why we sometimes call them water
bears or, even better in our opinion, moss piglets because
they are often in the aquatic environments
that cling to mosses.
But they are also very unlike macro-animals.
For one thing, they have eight legs.
For another thing they are not closely related
to anything else on earth.
Though taxonomists are still fighting about this, the leading system places tardigrades inside
a clade called Tactopoda that includes two
groups.
There's tardigrades and there's something called
Euarthropoda. And that other clade includes basically every bug, insects, arachnids, even crustaceans
and trilobites.
The organism that branched away from tardigrades has literally millions of species as its ancestor.
But the branch that tardigrades sit on...just tardigrades.
Though there are over 1000 described tardigrade species
and there are likely many times more than that out there.
But nonetheless, they do look a lot like bears with their claws and stumpy four pairs of legs.
Tardigrades hover right on the edge of microscopic.
They range widely in size from 50 microns long to 1200 microns
but usually, they're under 500 microns in size.
Tardigrades can be found in three major
aquatic environments.
Some live in marine or brackish water, others in fresh waters like ponds, lakes, and rivers,
and then there are the terrestrial habitats but this isn't exactly what it sounds like.
See, tardigrades do live on what we would
consider land, but they live in films of water
clinging to plants and dirt.
This thin film, though nearly invisible to
us, can be a Tardigrade’s whole world.
But these films can easily dry up in the daytime...which
is part of why Tardigrades are so good at
surviving difficult situations, which of course we’ll be discussing shortly.
They occupy almost every place on earth, from
the Arctic to the Antarctic, from soil to beach sand,
rivers, lakes, streams, on mosses, lichens,
algae and plants.
We know of a couple of places where we will almost certainly find them waddling around in samples
we take.
And we will make a whole episode about that process but that’s for later.
Although they are aquatic, tardigrades don’t swim, they kind of walk.
In fresh water, they live among vegetation
and mainly feed on the cell contents of plants
and algae by piercing the cells with the two
stylets they have in their mouthpart but
some species eat single-celled organisms or even other micro animals including rotifers
and also other tardigrades
Some species of tardigrades have eyes, besides helping them look super cute, they also boggle
the mind because they aren’t eyes.
To be an eye, you have to be an organ, and
to be an organ, you have to be composed of
tissues that are themselves composed of cells.
But each tardigrade eye is, in fact, a single
photoreceptive cell.
That is wild.
On their whole body, sometimes containing tens of thousands of cells,
they have two cells, and those two cells, are there two little eyes
Tardigrades are also covered in a kind of
skin, or shell, called a cuticle.
Coloration is produced by the pigmentation
of the cuticle and also the content of the digestive
tract.
Gray, bluish, yellow brown, reddish or brown
are common colors.
This cuticle always stays the same size, and
so must be shed as the tardigrade grows.
Some species of tardigrades lay their eggs
into this cuticle, which expands to hold them.
And then when the cuticle is shed, the eggs stay inside, giving them an extra layer of protection from
roving predators.
If those eggs manage to avoid being eaten, they will hatch into tiny, little tardigradelettes that,
oddly enough, have the same number of cells that they will always have.
But their cells, and thus their bodies, will
grow larger.
Tardigrades are marveolously complex for such
tiny animals, they have digestive systems
and salivary glands, even small brains.
The most complex have over 40,000 cells.
And yes, when they’re done extracting nutrients
from their food, they have to get rid of it
just like the rest of us.
Of course, tardigrades are best known for
their survival skills.
Many species have the ability to survive environmental extremes,
such as temperatures as low as -272 degrees Celsius and as high as 150 degrees celsius.
Extreme radiation.
Extreme pressures as high as 6000 atmospheres.
NASA sent a bunch of tardigrades
to outer space and brought them back alive
after exposing the animals to the vacuum of
space and extreme radiation from the sun.
A tardigrade may have a life-span of a couple
of weeks to more than 100 years.
A museum specimen of a dried moss that was in a herbarium for 120 years
yielded active tardigrades when soaked in water.
Tardigrades are able to survive these extremely hostile
conditions by undergoing a process known as
cryptobiosis.
In cryptobiosis, the metabolism of the tardigrades
can lower to less than 0.01% of normal and
when conditions get better the tardigrades simply get back to life.
There are actually several of kinds of cryptobiosis.
In Anhydrobiosis are dealing with a lack of water,
and they curl up into a ball called a tun to being all dried up
A glass-like protective sugar, trehalose is
synthesized and it replaces the water in the
cells of the tardigrades.
This sugar prevents crucial parts of the cells from getting damaged during water loss and
lets tardigrades to survive the dry period.
Anoxibiosis occurs when there is insufficient
oxygen.
The body of the tardigrade swells and becomes
rigid and turgid.
There is no movement and the tardigrade looks
dead.
This sometimes happens in our prepared slides.
So when it happens, we simply blow air into the slide from the side for around 10 seconds
and that is enough to increase the oxygen
concentration and “revive” the water bear.
And there are some other types of cryptobiosis such as cryobiosis where tardigrades can withstand
extremely low temperatures and osmobiosis where they can withstand changes in osmotic pressure.
One of the misconceptions about tardigrades
is that they are immortal.
They are resistant to these extreme conditions
when they are in tun state, but otherwise
they are quite delicate animals and can be
hurt and killed easily.
Because of their small size, tardigrades are eaten by some eve bigger single-celled organisms.
In this video, we managed to record a close encounter between tardigrade and a giant
eukaryote.
We don’t even know what this single-celled
organism here is, let us know if you think
you can identify it, but it could easily eat
the tardigrade and digest it.
But this lucky little one managed to escape and even damaged the cell of the eukaryote in the process
And in this clip we have a happy tardigrade
waddling on one of the most dangerous residents
of the ponds, a brown hydra.
Hydra’s tentacles are armed with something
called nematocysts.
These are like tiny harpoons that are fired upon contact to immobilize the hydra's prey.
This water bear was either very lucky or too small to activate the nematocysts and so got away
from a heartbreaking end.
Tardigrades are not extremophiles, they don’t
enjoy living in extreme conditions they are
just good at surviving them.
In that way, maybe they are something like
us.
We also sometimes live through situations
we thought would be impossible.
But, all things being equal, both tardigrades
and us just want a nice place to live, plenty
of yummy food, and whenever possible, to not be exposed to the vacuum of space.
We are so happy that these friends share
their world with us, so often just outside
of our notice, but successfully chomping their
way through the microcosmos for more than
half a billion years.
And just in case you wanted to see it again...
(laughs)
That's good.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us through the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James
check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us here at Journey to the Microcosmos,
I bet there's a subscribe button somewhere nearby.
We really appreciate everybody's kind words in the comments.
It really is just a joy to make this channel.